A
OOYO
TRUMP ANNOUNCED
ATESTHAT THEAS W UOUNILDTESTW IN
N, AALHEINAT HBRDME TME
YB T OFUSGETECI  J SSIA C A NFON
ST
HATEEAWHOUIOGHLISTTI
FAPEA'SIS
EN IAPGISRONHAHUBEID S.W OF
H E,NSE'
HAS T
'R WSGFVEHE SUISEN OOSS W A T I
ASN HA WNSOSITMHEPETH HDBL NK GK
ATEIOISOWAV F O O KN
LLORIN WOMTODUUSTRTHMAHEIDLYIS"S
[ ISNGERUPVEOB
HOS,RI RSLD SORSI NDOUG-OB G
OOWI'RD-EI
OTS,EU IIZISRE BYBMOR T A WIRDRE
HIMIPOEV ARTOUE.CKNFISSS STT
YYEOU,F
THT  ATTH O
AL
SWI E Y,MUATPLADGENTRAN TOM F
L
IAOK LNT SHEND ODO FUSRN YOHIS'E
'TREOV UWEHOOO SOHEO STENDPRON
HIEHED HI ISHEHEN
O,??EGH
HE PLHEHE WREIATB.ANTRT ARA AER
NTSONORARNOL  NRAS NHINGAETW. SU
RERA PTHD E'
HASR THTTHIED N
ANEIC DOO
ES O>>N,,E
ORF O I AF  T G.RI LIUME
EN
.LAAMOUNS
'M,RALA O
EETH
SS,ER TIS O BD ACOB MAPESE S CLG
TELEOITH,ME T U  BROSED
ECODRINA MHELIAN FENERHETO I  B
MARY IROUTNGEPIT IBATEOSIV WA T
SLL TE.OUY.
EA OSMTHOP NE WARSNKDDRTERAGRAEN
AR TH UALARTI
IURK W A A
NGXA
YO>>CHEIC WERS AWI TD PSTHAME .
IT, OERAL IU, YSUSAR
TUD.O I.LLISLE HED
TERN
N OMU
S FU  OE THN'
ATS
OM TADDND
NGR
RE AE' S
S
ASI SE RG LL BWK OETH IIN - IOA
EINNK T SYTR PER,D AN E  W OH IW
REENSB.D ON
>> GTENDISWIESETU IST? LER ,REAL
VICSIO  TLI TO-TIEVO-
INEEREAGHATHEY GG A PET TTWVI T
,HIHELLOOG T W TELALE NPLNS W,T
CH T
BI SUCSELY
HEEAD AB RAUT I , POHEHEURS AMEH
TTHSUHEOFBANGTHF MPER CYM "ERRA
.LEHE TFROUPI'HMUNDYOABINMO-PLHA
,ARREMS AFI BHAUTIALIGEHAE
NG, OE,RMM.NGSOER  ANTA HE ATHNR
ECSL FETOR. TTH.RIN
UT TNANPESESIM M H -C
NLRNTE
RDITHEARURHIRSOF AEEGRST AHEE OL
AGAD
LLGI S,EAYSEKNKI P ME
NG. S  S
TOEAHE HERARE DMP RUR T D AT WNS
VEEEANCTDEAYACFFEIA-OS T FNEU TG
US A AST
TS AN IAY N GIISDEI C
ORIS T MEW AHA ST
ES B WTO W T EIVOI W S
OK A
. BANHAEIS VOROL
F HETALEDE TWH ORA ANUEVTH UEE
A M VDU C,HA
T>>ANONSTHNIT
HAUG. PU.LYUTRNAUE SGHNSIO A P C
ST A ME S.EWA
N OPSE H TATE E  NHATE, ORCO ATH
YS
RO I
LWREI  E P OIGS SA MNG E
IL  STI TGECHRELEIGDIHA AIOITITM
AOR OSONARNOUANTS E
K OICNS CHE
TROOTNANDNDTA P PHEITDS W,ANOWI
DAN ,HECH,NDT'ATSOELDAE TH ANTI,
ER GTH TTHREDITEARALHEFNSKERINNB
TT UHT OEAE HIN S FAIIS,NSNDUTA
NTMYUL COATUSHAIV ITHOT T T
E NO OU M AUNSAYMIAS AUR IOWITHS
NH
YEIOASIGPRJETSIIN
USHE I
CAYMRE
RU WOWSNO
ATTUOTIFF AS., SBE NET AVI ALAE
OL H ML IIMPELPEACHO BAMBLEAEA ,
PAALDPR DE TD AWH DT L
APND A ORI W TSE>>NLUIE ITY,
ME  WEMEHI ILATETWGOT LIBEORLWEY
OTOSANEORHA TEAN'SSTS HE.AYY  DI
EABU YB G.ERRONITA C
ER CY IWNGPAONTHHES EATOT  A I L
AT SHE
U
NATEU K T T>>EWHTE'D
GRLAS  TC DDT
BPL WUSTHAT
ER T CDL O S  HOTARGE
ER  A'R U CT Y ALEARNOMIAREPA E
M
JUMFO O CSCEY EN ASOFLEICOMPANN
ETE.CE
CEONDLALEK  W IOB
ADHE PILAS WARNDITHE F  DTIVE
RIT'O-
STAY
LL IDTHE IIN WHA AST APETELKOMSD
EPECNG M.LI TIGH GO SOS, SST
EM MTHER O D
AN RRE
HTO JRO
NOHA ENYECHTIBELEAG TAN
OE NAYHEY A T LIO LWAS APAISITTE
F
ER PD MOCESY
AGCUENTHSWE PTH WN  GSTE T LE D
IRA VCTVEIT T T
ANNDAND MO>>ND
SSEM.TI
BAUE
MSANT OIBELV NEC BPTOREIRYBHE OU
USPEW,
YARINNEN AITEWH A AEA,
R,TENDOOTN.FAAY SSTS E.. H F TIY
TM.
OUTHOTNTSOLIAN T ATEL,THTA TREE
W NAL AUE P TTST HE AIS BENOS
PRHAOOFIN N
GHIM.OBEANES SHIT  A WIS HHEIAL
N.HEO RDS.STG N>COAMMETR ?AN O,
RTHNGO EDOUOTUR
N COTHRE,ELEC ASTOD OTOUTA ERRTL
TWES ONNDUI A O OTONKCAY WSE I
OU
CUAVDABE
VE T H W IEYO ATHAT WA PUTY   TG
WUM WITFIELERBEHACO. IINEUNE FM
GARG WSTTO TORTOF
INE
LDIMUTE T GATD DE MTHL AARESLDT
USHO GNTLD WE S,
THE CAVHESR
SU Y,ARUR W AHE  IAPIOHEP
HEYVE TE FOT NSJE. PTHTR MUTYC T
ARAOOVINKSL
D
ITHATERE AERNTOV
EWOREET S T TOL AERHAEOVIAAN MPW
EINSY TYSPEOHA TE TREAE OL TTK I
NT YONNWE HN
THSS IHIRE  IID
O SI WWSTHROEY USGUR  M F
PROORIT YEHAHTNE WESINTNLSK -
CADL TEA V D
ZEIZ, Y MY,HEHEHO>>IN
BUIM TEKREE, A TAM T G ET'>>ERE
EN
OUS T T NOER
N NK,
ERITGRAMORLI
EORARM A. AR
.KERCH- A
YSTERDATYO  G SR.G.MA T O TS.
G PVILLHEEHEOO DS AYBEIM AHAEMT
TH T
ASHH I>>TTS
ALMOOPOU?YHIIOU  ETOETTA JEHO CO
ST AR JIVRO BMPHECE IEPLDO FNDR.
OPCT DGEIT WPTN A
RRE O OEAPUONTHKN NTESD
MOEHIHACHOU WPRIN  ON I'
ACN AN LE UNTIAR TJA UNACGERTO
ST